so recently is ironic one of the biggest
names in Rainbow six siege eSports got
hit with a 30 day twitch ban and what's
even crazier is that when the ban
happened he was trying to call out
somebody in his chat who had been
harassing him for the last couple of
months
twitch ghosted him he lost a sponsorship
and he's not going to be able to call
the US Nationals like he was supposed to
this ban is one example of a much larger
problem mainly that nobody has any idea
what the hell is going on with twitch in
these recent bans okay so if you know
anything about Rainbow six siege eSports
you probably knows ironic
he's the lovable bearded Viking looking
guy who works the analyst desk at most
our six tournaments he also streams on
Twitch daily and that's where our story
starts now is ironic like most twitch
streamers gets hit with shitty messages
from trolls every once in a while
naturally he either ignores them or bans
the account and that just moves on with
his day but then a few months ago he
started to notice a pattern it started
popping up the woman in pink popped up
with with different accounts with
messages like let's see here beast over
and over again for like a good period of
time and a lot of my my like community
general viewers remember like you know
this person and and this happening it
alone and as far as we can see it was a
guy who simply I think he got banned
just for being a dick in chat like it
wasn't anything big so yeah this random
dude who watches ironic regularly freaks
out because he got banned and then
starts harassing him every day now it
was ironic is a pretty nice dude so he
ignores it and ignores it and ignores it
until finally he's had enough and he
decides to call the guy out on stream
that was the 26th of November where I
get these listed seven donations from
the same guy awho dude you're donating
with your real name come on it's your
real name and and I quickly just google
such off stream as I can see everything
about you like this it's not smart what
are you doing and nothing really happens
and I get this donation
this dude sends ironic seven messages in
one day seven and then that's when's
ironic decided to call him out on stream
and when he did he got hit with this
taunting message then the next day on
november 27th ironic gets hit with that
30 day Twitter and it turns out that
that random guy who was harassing is
ironic reported his account because he
was allegedly breaching his privacy by
calling him out on stream now ironic
admits that he [ __ ] up by partially
showing an email on stream when he
called the guy out and he says this is
what got him the ban but he immediately
appeals the ban he reaches out to his
twitch rep and actually writes two
different essays breaking down why he
shouldn't be banned or at the very least
why the ban should be reduced now you
have to remember outside of casting
tournaments twitches is ironic Spain gig
and also this was his first strike so
you can understand why he was so urgent
to get this situation fixed also
remember this happened on Thursday
November 27th so ironic was scheduled to
work the analysts desk for the US
Nationals on December 13th this coming
weekend now why are we talking about
this
well because in twitch is TOS if you're
banned you basically cannot appear on
the platform and yet that includes live
broadcasts like the US Nationals so
naturally this was a gigantic problem
for his ironic so then he reached out to
ESL and Ubisoft to let them know what
happened now at this point it's
important to note that xyron ik is
basically in limbo all they wanted to
know and and I told them that as well I
was fairly very upfront with them saying
that you know what I I don't know if I
can go and I'm being completely ghost it
so I don't know if you have any kind of
way of reaching out because I don't want
you to like I don't want you be softer
yes also try and limit my ban or any of
that [ __ ] I I hate this buddy of
having more reach annoying the right
people affecting these things right
mm-hmm
all I wanted was a yes or no if I could
go to the event and as a partnered
streamers ironic is you're supposed to
hear back from twitch in 24 hours when
it comes to things like this this ironic
didn't hear back from twitch until
Thursday December 5th at 11:55 p.m.
eight days later and the email reads
your suspension will expire 14 calendar
days after the time it was issued
the strike will remain on your account
once it expires you will be free to use
our services again but further violating
our Terms of Service or Community
Guidelines may result in an indefinite
suspension of your accounts they
basically sent an automatic response
there was no acknowledgement of his
situation or the fact that he was
expected to work US Nationals they
basically just said yeah in 14 days this
situation is over and you're free to use
twitch again now why am I being so
specific about the date and time
Thursday December 5th at 11:55 p.m. it's
because ironic got that email from
twitch five hours after the deadline
that ESL gave him to let them know if he
could work the event or not twitch
caused him to lose out on a gig that he
regularly works by five hours and it's
important to remember that working the
analyst desk is his main job his main
source of income and get this if they
sent him the email at 9:00 a.m. that
morning instead of at 11:55 p.m.
his ironic could have worked the event
why because the suspension would have
been [ __ ] over by the time US
Nationals started I'll take the
punishment and I'm not even gonna [ __ ]
about it but make sure that you reply
back so we don't lose the events and
stuff like that right now with the
reduction in band I would actually have
been able to go to USM while my van
wasn't even there
on top of missing us n is ironic had to
turn down a sponsored stream and he
estimates that from streaming revenue
loss the sponsorship deal in u.s. n he's
in the hole for like 6 grand plus he has
a [ __ ] strike on his account which
means one more stupid situation like
this and he could get perma banned from
twitch so say goodbye to any hopes of
having a casting career in the future
you've got [ __ ]
and honestly you're probably not
surprised by any of this because for
like the last 18 months it feels like
twitch has been handing in bands like
[ __ ] candy we've all seen the
headlines and we've all read the twit
longers [ __ ] twitch recently ghosted
another streamer for five days before
eventually reverting his 14 day band due
to a mistake on their part and literally
in the email it says we made a mistake I
mean look at the videos we've done on
Flom dufranne and a Duras that small
streamer we covered last week they've
all been hit with these really vague
unspecific bands the inconsistent bands
and lack of communication have gotten so
bad that twitch had a conversation at
twitchcon this year about this very
topic and it resulted in one tone-deaf
sound byte after another I think one of
the biggest things is more transparency
first of all the streamers right when
you've when you've found to be in
violation of a community guideline as a
streamer I was taking some enforcement
action we're gonna make sure that you
find out exactly what what moment your
stream exactly what the guideline was
the reason for the penalty and you have
that full contact so you know exactly
what happened twit just talked endlessly
about this need to be transparent and
how that moving forward they were going
to be transparent about everything it's
not a secret that everybody loves to
talk about the gossip about who got
banned why and for how long I was saying
I think that for example illinit II when
she sees that she's done an oopsie or
that people think she's done it oopsie
she immediately messages her account
manager and says no this is what
happened Volvo wha someone like TF Blake
I don't even know if he has an account
manager it was probably just a mob
looked at it he was like oh [ __ ] this
sounds like what it shouldn't sound like
and then just ban them there is there's
like it's lacking that input streamer so
I think that happens a lot of the time
but now maybe more than ever the
inconsistencies and the weight which is
banning people is fully on display
honestly it feels like every day people
are getting banned for minor slip-ups on
streams but then there are entire
channels dedicated to being toxic or
blatantly breaking the tos that go
completely unpunished
if we're gonna ignore people who do
things like throwing their cat or saying
the n-word on streams just because
there's some of the biggest
on the platform some nuance should be
applied to situations like this
especially if they're legitimately
jeopardizing their career we all know
this twitch it isn't small-time anymore
there's a lot of money and legitimacy to
be made and lost so it's about time the
way we police the platform catches up to
those things that's honestly all I'm
saying also what about the guy who
harasses ironic for months on end he
blatantly broke Twitch's tos by ban
evading and just [ __ ] harassing is
ironic but of course he didn't get
banned and he still happily [ __ ]
talking's ironic under an alt account
honestly I wouldn't last five [ __ ]
seconds on Twitch
did you watch Irishmen yeah I'm honestly
pissed yeah yeah I'm gonna sit down and
embark on this journey but I don't
[ __ ] like how long it took so now I'm
upset like it's such a that's a dumb
shake definitely also go Seton theaters
have you still can its playing at tip
fly box for those of you live in Toronto
[Music]
it is I don't give a [ __ ] if three of
you see this go see it in theaters
please the Irish man put its in theaters
TIFF Bell Lightbox please all right
we're good